how's it going bros my name is pierre de
ba then today I have with me ink ink
inking she won't be seeing though it's
too dark I'm sorry ink anyway welcome to
mr. chapter 3 the first to Alice Kali
right about how a penny I mean hello
Spiti I like the fire it's pretty
closely can you please leave me okay
fine fine
I really like fetish chapter 1 and
chapter 2 so this should begin I hope at
least you never know I like closets
turban cos is not friendly to see this
one doesn't open open I'm telling I just
ah we got Latin and then Matt that's
pity
why didn't you see why are you talking
to Scully for before you're talking to
me I'm sorry I'm sorry it's funny but
since though we need to go and finish
this chapter alright get key
[Music]
what was that spawner ah I would that
with a deli if you don't stop him again
hit me Manuel the fling and dine now I
won't tell you now I won't tell you are
you happy are you happy now you know Oh
[ __ ] head quarters no way I pity it
could be cool I mean no it's not cool
actually I hate car toys too
barrels great I'm gonna put you what are
you doing here at ratrock ah okay you
stay there
and I see you talking through the bra
I'll [ __ ] kill you I don't know how
you kill a barrel but round
I hate barrels okay they sway PD all
right goodbye
you're not be there you look really good
in this darkness
hey just don't stay focused okay hi
what's going on here
got a breakup
holy [ __ ] driver there it was awesome do
you think I look good in them I'm not
gonna turn to the father into piggy all
right heck are we going it's follow any
clues I of K of cars okay yes we we I bi
Wow okay just
may I don't trust this half-opened door
okay biggie I put a book yeah I'm so
frigging pop mm-hmm mmhmm mm-hmm
you thought about the peg you thought I
was a pig no I'm a mattress I mattress
all right fine I'll leave take it for
now but the heck is he doing there I
don't understand this is kind of where
oh
bro bro bro there's the ahh
Panda look at my buddy uh rough day
whatever happened there I'll never know
Mike can jump scares me where's the
funny
what are you doing overage palette I
tried to save you but you know I wasn't
trying to run away or anything brother
the heck is going on here buddy okay I
know you're naked and stuff but I'm
gonna take your [ __ ] all right
line 9 i madam am signing portions I
don't care I need it I need it I don't
know why I need it but I need it all
right fine you can stay there you can be
dead you ignore me whatever you want
wait we got the key right yeah don't
drop me I hate you pity IIIA Caramba are
we going anyway wait we got the key for
doesn't even say hey I remember nice
here probably all right we're good when
it goes like this
it's like progress only Keys breaking
just gut
be they I'm sorry but I have to leave
you Oh fine you'll be fine okay there we
go
during this for science ends the panel I
think not okay I just got to find him
oh wow what a total coincidence at us
pity I was waiting for you all right
fine
that's fair enough just you and me buddy
always I'm together forever and you're
breaking [ __ ] as usual
hey there's Thor you can't hide in the
oh wow that was cheap
how [ __ ] my supposed to survive that
where was I ah ah ah
that got me good they're gonna be [ __ ]
get my leg anyway but ah I'm gonna get a
heart attack one of these days holy
what the heck is go bother us pity I am
the real stefana but nice Asteria super
duper uber uber stephannie
yes I did say stupid I'm not worthy oh
[ __ ] that's the big stuff this is
getting ridiculous I think this is the
last custom mod made for me I'll play
you in a wife it's funny as hell but
Jesus Christ vomits take chill but this
heavy are you doing bra white here the
rapist hits the father already go ah oh
yeah alright oh that's pity you will
take me with you
once you okay okay this way we do if I
just get fit
I know I hate the line of Christmas food
but I think I'm gonna at leaves brah
it's okay pity just finish this map and
do it good
ah
ahh bra bra bra bra all right again why
doesn't leave all these solid can just
be locked or something
I don't trust quarters like
oh go oh oh
Boober I was a [ __ ] poof a [ __ ]
poof where's Evan everywhere Wow
I was he wasn't that I know
hey Amy
I ain't yeah stop right all right
oh go go okay we're good huh
it's [ __ ] cussin
by
[Applause]
all right breaking the challah man
freaking lava stones I touch it it's no
problem
oh [ __ ] it's hot all right lucky stones
you ain't got [ __ ] on me
all right we get help with these what
the heck is going on here okay I'm not
going there
Frigga to Frank what the heck is this
oh well fair enough why don't have
somebody oh that's custom stories for
you I guess I have to jump down here I
have no choice bros all right
let's do it your honorable oh wait hey
you like my ladder and ladder jump I
like that [ __ ] hey what am i doing down
here hey what a jump down here that was
pretty I'm G though you got you gotta
admit that was a movie that wasn't Emily
I don't know I don't even know what I'm
gonna do yet I could've meant that moji
I was could have been my family gee why
didn't I go down there I don't
understand
where's my lantern not working okay
there we go
but seriously though why are we looking
for mystery wait maybe we need this
super this castings rocks and maybe
we're gonna throw them this back what is
this anyway
oh I know maybe we're gonna make a
bridge over I know I know I knew that I
know that before you know it I know it
for you that just Johnny get this out of
here
through the wall or whatever it's fine
no problem
alright we get oh all right
no bro you're doing it wrong bra bra bra
from [ __ ] trying to do this okay yep
we're doing it are you doing it it's
good Oh stay but ah nah God dang it
let's do this I have one two three a lot
of adepts is this supposed to be stuck
there I don't hope leave Kelly's gonna
walk like - Matt yeah don't hit anything
I brought alright we're good
I can't run with this [ __ ] in my hands
that's what she's then okay let's go
yes I made it holy [ __ ] I'm awesome I
did that spawn huh
where's my mr. sheriff what's going on
here miss Chan I don't know baby but
don't look at me like this
I'm disappointed you I'm really first I
thought we were friends
hey sit down baby okay now that on me
Jesus cry I thought we were French PT
but you never share ma I'm seriously
disappointed you can't I bring oh [ __ ]
dad was any louder I probably would
okay we got the machine room key I need
no bra Wow oh [ __ ] all right
bras I think it's not for today I'll see
you tomorrow right
I forgot to stop recording there we go
[Music]
I am okay let's go here look share mode